si
monsieur le Président Madame la
Directrice donc vous achevez cet
après-midi d'audition que nous avons
débuté
à 15h nous vous remercions bien sûr de
vous être rendus disponible dans cette
excuse pour le quart d'heure de décalage
donc monsieur le Président Peltier vous
êtes avocat spécialisé en droit de
l'immobilier et en droit des affaires
après avoir été président de l'Union
nationale de la propriété immobilière
l'une pie vous êtes devenu en 1998
président de l'Agence nationale de
l'habitat Lana et ce pendant 10 ans donc
jusqu'en 2008 vous avez ensuite présidé
le Comité opérationnel sur les bâtiments
existants à l'occasion des premières
réflexions autour du Grenelle de
l'environnement votre rôle c'est ensuite
élargie au sein du comité stratégique du
Plan Bâtiment Grenelle dont le premier
ministre vous avez nommé président en
janvier
9 vous avez depuis été reconduit dans
vos fonctions à la tête de ce plan qui a
été rebaptisé depuis Plan Bâtiment
Durable il y a 10 ans et c'est bien sûr
à ce titre que nous vous avons convié ce
soir le plan que vous présidez a pour
but de mobiliser les acteurs du bâtiment
et de l'immobilier en vue de l'atteinte
des objectifs de les d'efficacité
énergétique et environnementale a signé
à ce secteur vous nous présenterez
l'historique le fonctionnement et le
bilan de ce Plan Bâtiment Durable madame
Marie gratia vous avez été chargé de
mission puis chef de projet au sein du
Plan Bâtiment Durable donc auprès de
Monsieur Pelletier vous êtes en
particulier attaché à développer des
actions de communication et surtout à
animer les réseaux d'acteurs des
filières concernées par le plan c'est
donc assez naturellement que vous êtes
ensuite devenu il y a exactement un an
directrice du collectif et fit énergie
qui est une association en charge
d'accompagner ses membres dans la
conception la rénovation et la
construction de bâtiments précurseurs à
faible impact énergétique et
environnemental c'est votre collectif
qui anime par exemple l'Observatoire BBC
et qui est la borne notamment les labels
Bâtiments Basse Consommation et bas
carbone ou BBC bâtiment à énergie
positive bpost et bpost plus et si
l'énergie patrimoine et synergie
re2020 vous nous en direz plus sur le
détail de vos actions dans un instant
madame monsieur outre la présentation
des activités des structures que vous
représentez nous souhaitons aussi vous
entendre comme force de proposition vous
partagerez ainsi avec nous vos analyses
franches et informés des politiques
publiques actuelles en matière de
rénovation énergétique on en soulignant
les qualités mais aussi les défauts dont
vous nous ferez part en outre également
on attend bien sûr vos préconisations
peut-être pour l'avenir vous nous
expliquerez comment procéder selon vous
pour massifier pour rendre plus efficace
et accélérer la rénovation énergétique
des logements avant de vous laisser la
parole pour répondre à ses premières
questions et pour un propos introductif
une quinzaine de minutes il me revient
de vous indiquer que cette audition est
diffusée en direct et en différé sur le
site internet du Sénat et qu'elle fera
bien sûr l'objet d'un compte-rendu je
dois également vous rappeler qu'un faux
témoignage devant notre commission
d'enquête serait passible des peines
prévues aux articles
434-13
434-14 et 434-15 du code pénal qui
peuvent aller de trois ans à 7 ans
d'emprisonnement et de 45000 euros à
100000 euros d'amende je vous invite
donc à prêter serment de dire toute la
vérité rien que la vérité et à lever la
main droite et à dire je le jure
et bien je vous en remercie je vous cède
la parole et ensuite notre rapporteur
bien sûr ne manquera pas de vous poser
un certain nombre de questions
complémentaires
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur mesdames messieurs
un mot très bref
pour expliquer ce qu'est le Plan
Bâtiment Durable puisque
j'espère où je commence à espérer que 14
ans de déploiement de travaux
commencent à lui donner un début de
notoriété le Plan Bâtiment Durable c'est
aujourd'hui
18 à 20 000 personnes sur l'ensemble de
la France que nous avons rassemblé ou
que nous rassemblons autour de ce seul
projet
faire en sorte que
les bâtiments à l'horizon 2050
soit basse consommation et assure la
neutralité carbone
le plan s'organise autour de trois
fonctions principales la première qui a
nourri ses premières années de manière
intense c'est une force de proposition
au risque d'être immodeste la grande
part
des dispositifs
qui
ont pu émailler projet et proposition de
loi ou des textes réglementaires
trouvent son origine dans nos groupes de
travail je donne juste
des exemples très simples premiers c'est
le plus peut-être le plus spectaculaire
c'est la réglementation environnementale
nous avons dit
dès que la réglementation thermique 2012
en traite en vigueur à la demande de
l'administration qui m'avait mandaté à
ce propos que le cycle des
réglementations thermiques devaient
cesser et nous avons alors ouvert la
voie à ce couple énergique carbone qui
caractérise la réglementation
environnementale et nous avions posé une
autre idée qui a été mise en œuvre par
le gouvernement qui est pas de
réglementation sans une expérimentation
et
c'est le référentiel E+ c'est moins qui
avait été mis en place à l'époque par
Emmanuel cosse
et je pourrais multiplier les exemples
mais ce n'est probablement pas
intéressant
donc premièrement force de proposition
deuxièmement une force de mobilisation
et notamment sur les territoires
nous avons et ça a été un peu fluctuant
mais nous avons
[Musique]
inventé avec l'aide
de la du président des régions
concernées du préfet de région nous
avons inventé des plans bâtiments
durables régionaux le dernier en date
qui s'est créé et celui de l'Occitanie
et le premier avait été celui de la
Bretagne qui avait en somme rassemblé
les réseaux que nous réunissons au plan
national au plan local pour déterminer
dans le cadre du grand projet à
l'horizon 2050 qui avait été construit
par le Grenelle de l'environnement puis
par la loi de programmation Grenelle 1
de 2009 comment compte tenu des
particularismes locaux on pouvait
atteindre l'objectif et l'expérience
mais qui est une banalité pour des
sénateurs proches des réalités
territoriales c'est qu'il y a autant de
chemin pour parvenir au même objectif
qu'il y a de zones régionales parce que
les cultures l'architecture le climat
etc ne sont pas identiques et conduisent
à créer des priorités différenciées
et le troisième
mode d'action du Plan Bâtiment Durable
c'est d'organiser des concertations et
nous sommes en ce moment
ultra sollicités pour cela
j'ai été chargé d'animer l'écriture de
la feuille de route à la demande du
Parlement Article 301 de la loi climat
et résilience la feuille du feuille de
route décarbonation du secteur
économique du bâtiment
nous je suis en ce moment chargé par la
ministre de la transition énergétique
d'animer
l'écriture du plan de sobriété dans le
parc résidentiel et dans le parc
tertiaire à l'horizon
donc plan de sobriété 2 comme il est dit
et
voilà donc je réunis des gens différents
qui sont ceux au réseau et en mettant
des gens différents autour d'une table
mon expérience et qu'on parvient
toujours à des consensus parfois ce ne
sont pas des consensus très
révolutionnaires parce qu'il faut
arriver à rendre compte des différences
du groupe mais on arrive toujours à des
propositions pour clore cela j'ai
apporté de choses la série des petits
ouvrages sans grande prétention haute
que de sensibilisation que nous publions
et puis j'ai fait un petit tour sur le
site du Plan Bâtiment Durable pour
piocher parmi la quarantaine de rapports
que l'on a fait ce qui me paraissent
intéressant pour éclairer votre mission
et il suffit de s'y reporter il y a
juste la page de couverture voilà
peut-être Marie va présenter synergie
puis je reprends la parole
merci
donc pour présenter rapidement le
collectif et synergie vous l'avez dit on
est une association qui a été créée en
2006 qui est aujourd'hui reconnu
d'intérêt général et qui regroupe une
soixantaine d'adhérents des
collectivités en premier lieu notamment
des régions qui ont été à l'initiative
de la création du collectif et synergie
des acteurs de la filière bâtiment
engagés sur sur ces sujets là fédération
organisation professionnelle acteur de
la recherche du financement
et des entreprises et des associations
et notre objectif derrière et de porter
collectivement une ambition sur le sujet
de la performance énergétique et
environnementale des bâtiments et de
généraliser les constructions et les
rénovations les plus performantes
possible sur nos actions brièvement
vous l'avez mentionné on porte des
labels préchaigurateurs en matière de
rénovation c'est le label BBC rénovation
qui est un label régle
[Musique]
on va remonter l'ensemble des projets
qui sont labellisés mais aussi des
projets de construction et de rénovation
qui sont accompagnées par des
collectivités territoriales avec
l'objectif de mettre à disposition de
l'ensemble des acteurs ce retour
d'expérience
c'est un site en ligne gratuit
accessible à tous qui vient alimenter
notamment des enseignants lors de
formation mais aussi qui nous permet
d'alimenter les pouvoirs publics pour
savoir qu'est-ce qu'on est capable de
faire ou pas sur ce type de telle et tel
type de bâtiment
et notre expertise on la met aussi au
profit de projets de recherche et
d'innovation quelques sujets qu'on a en
cours en lien avec la rénovation d'abord
le sujet du BBC par étape j'y reviendrai
aussi un peu plus tard mais c'est une
expérimentation qu'on a menée depuis
plusieurs années avec un certain nombre
de partenaires qui nous permet
aujourd'hui de définir une méthodologie
de ce que peut être la rénovation par
étape et je Rev que je ne résume pas du
tout à la rénovation par geste et on
fera le distinguo on a aussi mené
dernièrement une expérimentation autour
du patrimoine et de la réhabilitation du
patrimoine comment attendre des niveaux
de performance élevée lorsqu'on rénove
du patrimoine tout en préservant leur
qualité patrimoniales c'était la
question qu'on a posé il y a maintenant
un peu plus de trois ans avec là aussi
un certain nombre de projets qui nous
permettent de faire des recommandations
des orientations sur la façon dont on
peut rénover ce patrimoine parce que
c'est possible d'intervenir sur ce
patrimoine sans le détériorer et enfin
des projets autour de la mesure de la
performance réelle des rénovations
énergétiques performantes au niveau BBC
équivalent et en accompagnement depuis
plusieurs années des sociétés de tiers
financement pour les aider à développer
leur offre sur l'ensemble du territoire
donc c'est un bref éventail de nos
activités les labels sont certainement
la partie la plus connue de ce qu'on
peut porter chez synergie j'ai tendance
à dire que ça allait un petit peu la
partie émergée de l'iceberg il y a
beaucoup de travaux derrière qui nous
permettent d'alimenter ce travail là et
les référentiels qu'on peut produire
je reprends la parole si vous le voulez
bien pour développer rapidement sur le
fond
l'idée que j'ai envie de de transmettre
à votre commission
cette idée elle se distingue en deux
temps d'abord une appréciation sur la
situation actuelle ce que j'ai appelé
les tailles existants et puis en une un
effort de prospective pour voir ce qui
pourrait se passer que j'appelle l'état
projeté pour reprendre des termes qui
sont familiers au champ de l'immobilier
je ne
je n'adhère pas du tout à la lecture ou
aux propos qu'on entend trop souvent sur
le fait que
nous sommes toutes on a raté l'action en
matière de rénovation énergétique il se
passe rien
que c'est la gabegie etc je ne pense pas
du tout et
je
c'est mon premier intervention pour
montrer les lumières mais aussi les
ombres qui caractérisent la situation
actuelle et puis ensuite je vous
proposerai
deux façons d'entrevoir l'avenir une
première façon qui est que j'ai appelé
l'ajustement
c'est-à-dire on garde les mêmes règles
mais on bouge ici ou là un curseur on
aménage on améliore et les voies
d'amélioration existent c'est une des
voies possibles et l'autre voit que
j'appelle de mes vœux c'est on appellera
ça les cyclistes appelleront ça le
changement de braquet les cavaliers
appelleront ça le changement de pied
on se dit et c'est là-dessus je vais
peut-être consacrer un peu plus de temps
on se dit que la question de la
rénovation du bâti est une question qui
va occuper plusieurs dizaines d'années
qu'elle justifie une politique
industrielle et on s'y met et c'est ça
que je voudrais vous proposer alors sur
le l'état existant des éléments de
stabilité intéressant le premier je l'ai
évoqué tout à l'heure c'est le fait
assez sidérant dans notre organisation
républicaine que un cap posé en annoncé
en 2007 posé en 2009 à l'horizon 2050
demeure et à résister à toutes les
majorités qui se sont succédées jusqu'à
aujourd'hui
il y a bien sûr eu pour atteindre ce cap
des moments où le vent était plus
portant que d'autres des moments on a
tiré des bords peut-être quelques
moments on a mis un peu à la cape mais
enfin le l'objectif n'a pas dévié je
pense que c'est une force inouïe pour
notre sujet le deuxième élément qui se
caractérise par
l'observation que 650
000 personnes
se sont tournées vers l'Agence nationale
de l'habitat pour
solliciter ma prime rénove en une année
montre que les esprits ont évolué
considérablement que la question de la
rénovation énergétique elle est
maintenant dans les têtes et un exemple
récent qui montrerait qu'il n'y a pas
que les ménages qui ont compris la
nécessité de bouger à l'égard de leur
bâti dans la une réunion sobriété à
laquelle je
ne supporte plus de voir de la gabegie
de voir de l'énergie gaspillée de voir
la chaleur qui quitte les lieux parce
que les portes sont pas fermées la
lumière trop intense etc et comme un
seul homme ils sont tous venus nous dire
les efforts considérables qu'il voulait
mener oui la société a changé et ce sont
ces années qui l'ont qui l'ont permis
dans le même temps les programmes qu'on
a mené notamment ma prime rénov qui le
traduit on continue à manifester une
attention prioritaire au soutien des
plus fragiles de notre société
les chiffres de ma prime rénove montrent
que ce sont principalement les ménages
modestes qui en bénéficient si je dis
cette question c'est parce que ça a été
ma première préoccupation lorsqu'en 2009
j'ai démarré vous le verrez dans les
travaux qu'on a fait le premier groupe
de travail était la lutte contre la
précarité énergétique et c'est nous qui
avons inventé ce qui ensuite est devenu
le programme Habiter mieux qui s'est
ensuite
transformé au fil des ans donc
l'idée que un plan
qu'une politique publique sur la
rénovation puisse se mener sans mettre
en priorité les plus fragiles ceux qui
ont froid chez eux
ce qui produiront de l'effet rebond
parce que l'économie d'énergie ou du
moins l'isolation de leur bâti va leur
faire consommer l'énergie qui ne
consomme pas aujourd'hui faute de
ressources doit être une priorité en
permanence affirmée nous avons aussi
c'est encore le Plan Bâtiment Durable
inventé l'écho conditionnalité des aides
en s'inspirant de ce que à l'époque la
région
Basse-Normandie pratiquait la région
distribuée des subventions et avait dit
qu'elle ne les distribuerait qu'à des
travaux exécutés par des artisans
qualifiés
et on a trouvé que c'était une bonne
idée d'où l'invention progressive de
cette certification reconnue garant de
l'environnement
dont on peut discuter des des faiblesses
actuelles bonne chose aussi pour moi la
fin du crédit d'impôt
de la transition énergétique
qui développait un effet d'aubaine qui
m'a paru tout à fait excessif et et je
pense que c'est donc une bonne chose de
l'avoir abandonnée bonne chose que la
mise en place de France rénov
aujourd'hui déjà 550 points conseils sur
le territoire
bonne chose d'avoir favorisé
[Musique]
un peu un peu de travail collaboratif
entre les différentes structures
ministérielles et administratives en
charge du sujet la coordination
interministérielle à la rénovation
énergétique est une bonne invention
voilà et
je m'arrête là sur les lumières quelques
ombres
bon les aides trop compliquées
les aides trouvent versatiles
le statut de la copropriété en chantier
permanent
tout cela ne favorise pas
une dynamique de l'action
puisque
la complexité et le changement ainsi que
à l'attente d'un certain nombre
d'acteurs les rénovations par gestes
dont à l'égard desquelles j'ai toujours
émis des réserves assez fortes alors je
les ai je le fais pas publiquement parce
que ce n'est pas mon rôle mais j'ai eu
des propos très clairs à l'égard des
ministres concernés en leur disant que
je ne croyais pas cette idée que un
geste en appellerait un autre car c'est
l'idée de départ qui a été porté je
pense qu'elle ne se traduit pas dans les
faits que les choses sont plus
compliquées que cela et que l'engagement
de travaux l'est et depuis le début je
porte l'idée de bouquet de travaux
[Musique]
actions ou trois actions qui permettent
de conduire vers la rénovation globale
sans en avoir la rigueur
[Musique]
également
la pilotage public trop morcelé
aujourd'hui je m'adresse à une
secrétaire d'État pour évoquer les le
rôle des collectivités territoriales un
ministre délégué au Budget pour éviter
pour évoquer l'immobilier de l'État à la
ministre de la transition énergétique au
ministre de la transition écologique au
ministre de la Ville et du logement vous
connaissez cela ils ont beau
s'entendre
fonctionner ensemble c'est une
complexité
probablement
la coordination interministérielle qui
est une excellente idée n'est pas
suffisamment dotée pour peser fortement
me semble-t-il et puis la main donné au
collectivités territoriales n'y est pas
au niveau où elle devrait l'être alors
l'état projeté
je vais peut-être passer rapidement sur
le la première branche de l'alternative
c'est à dire ajuster parce qu'on somme
on voit bien ce qu'on peut régler
comment on peut améliorer les choses
je vais juste
prendre deux points qui me paraissent
être très attractif
si les aides restent compliquées et il
est probablement difficile d'en réduire
beaucoup la complexité parce que les
émetteurs des aides sont multiples
ce ne serait pas sous un sous une aide
unique qu'on pourrait mobiliser l'aide
de telle intercommunalité ou de la
région qui viennent s'ajouter aux aides
d'État
par exemple au programme spéciaux qui
qui interviennent donc je pense qu'il
faut renoncer à cette à l'idée d'aide
unique qu'en revanche il faut imaginer
l'idée de dossier unique c'est-à-dire au
moins que nous ayons une harmonie des
critères qui permettent d'accéder aux
aides au moins que le dossier unique
soit constitué par une personne qui
évite au ménage de soulever le capot et
de voir la complexité du moteur qui est
en dessous on n'a pas besoin de ça pour
conduire une voiture
et je pense qu'il y a là une voie
intéressante l'autre voit qui est tout à
fait impérative
la représentation nationale dans la loi
climat et résiliente à créer une
obligation de rénovation pour les
bailleurs privés qui veulent le demeurer
puisque les logements énergivores
cesseront d'être dans le parc locatif
privé s'il demeure énergivore
je
j'acquiais à cette à ce chemin
[Musique]
son tempo est soutenus pour ne pas dire
très ambitieux
et il est impératif sans attendre
de voir quelles sont les mesures
nécessaires pour accompagner les
bailleurs privés dans cet effort je
pense notamment à l'idée d'un
amortissement accéléré des travaux qui
viendraient compléter ce que vous avez
décidé dans la loi de finances pour 2023
en doublant le déficit foncier imputable
je crois que le déficit foncier ne
répond pas à tous les cas et qu'un
amortissement accéléré des travaux par
le ré en revanche et c'est là-dessus que
je termine mais c'est pour moi
l'essentiel
qu'attendons pour construire une
politique industrielle du sujet et en
somme je vais l'illustrer par
deux observations la première
observation se faisant je dis que
l'offre de travaux et de services
n'est pas
suffisamment performante sur l'ensemble
du territoire
ce qui ne met en rien en cause la
qualité des personnes qui animent cette
offre mais il y a là un travail tout à
fait considérable à mener porter
l'ensemble de ceux qui exécutent les
travaux et les services à l'immeuble en
somme je
visionne une industrie mobilière qui va
des industriels qui fournissent les
matériaux équipements jusqu'au gardien
de
de la copropriété ou du logement social
c'est l'ensemble de cette chaîne
ce qui construisent qui rénove
qui mesure qui accompagne les
architectes etc mais ceux qui financent
qui assurent qui maintiennent qui gère
les transactions qui gèrent les biens en
location etc il y a une chaîne très
grande de personnes et cette chaîne que
je qualifie d'industrie immobilière n'a
pas fait la mue que d'autres branches de
l'industrie dans notre pays ont réalisé
donc premier sujet l'offre et deuxième
sujet
et c'est probablement la méthode pour y
parvenir pour parvenir à transformer
cette offre c'est changer la maille
d'intervention
nous n'atteindrons jamais les objectifs
que nous nous assignons si nous
continuons à raisonner au logement
ou à l'immeuble collectif le
raisonnement il est celui de
la centralité d'une ville d'un quartier
n'a pas été de maison il est celui en
somme
et les dix ans passés à la présidence de
Lana m'inspire sur ce point de ce que
réussit si bien les opérations
programmées d'amélioration de l'habitat
en arrivant
sous la
le rôle d'ensemble oublié du maire ou du
président de l'intercommunalité
donc sous cette direction de terrain a
assuré l'unité de temps d'espace et de
lieu et d'action qui finissent par
remporter tous les gens concernés par
cet espace et si on se met dans cette
voie là c'est à dire à dire la maille
d'intervention elle est large
on arrête de
d'accompagner chacun dans son couloir de
nage les bailleurs sociaux font leurs
choses de leur côté l'immeuble de
l'immobilier de l'État dans l'autre les
copropriétaires c'est l'ensemble de
cette diversité d'immobilier qui est
concernée par le projet qu'on emmène et
je garantis que si on fait cela on va
voir les gros du BTP qui pour le moment
de s'intéresse pas à la rénovation
énergétique d'un pavillon voir d'un
lotissement
s'intéresser à ces sujets dont l'ampleur
sera grande et on verra les promoteurs
qui sont d'excellents professionnels qui
peinent aujourd'hui à trouver des
parcelles pour ne faire que du neuf
s'intéresser au recyclage de l'existant
qui donnera lieu à des extensions de
construction en surélévation ou en
adjonction du bâti existant bref on aura
des opérateurs nouveaux
si on décide cela ce ne sera plus un
gros mot que d'évoquer la construction
hors site c'est-à-dire la construction
modulaire qui se fait aussi protéger qui
permet d'accélérer le rythme de
construction et d'assurer des chantiers
propres
c'est un grand mouvement qui permettra
alors de donner au ménage et aux
entreprises qui assureront la rénovation
de leurs locaux une garantie de
performance qui aujourd'hui ne peut pas
être émise faute de trouver une contre
garantie mais ça suppose et je sais les
derniers mots ça suppose que tout le
monde s'y mette qu'on arrive à mobiliser
les réseaux bancaires qui sont des
grands absents du financement de la
rénovation énergétique malgré les
efforts
successifs et en vain d'un certain
nombre d'acteurs qui ont travaillé sur
le sujet j'ai été mandaté sur le sujet
et j'ai échoué comme d'autres on fait
après moi
le et à défaut d'arriver à ce que les
réseaux bancaires qui ont d'autres
logiques puissent être embarqué
peut-être faudra-t-il se rabattre sur un
modèle à l'allemand ou une banque dédiée
la CAF W portent le financement de la
rénovation énergétique peut-être
serait-ce une fois encore la banque des
territoires qui sera mobilisée mais on a
là un sujet majeur et notamment la
disparition du Crédit Foncier de France
du moins sa dilution dans l'ensemble
BPCE a eu comme effet que la
distribution qui s'accélérait des
éco-prés collectifs aux copropriété qui
permettaient aux syndic de dire aux
copropriétaires je lisse la dépense sur
15 ans et je m'occupe de tout le et je
m'occupe de tout étant très important
se trouve aujourd'hui être réduit à la
portion congrue même si deux organismes
continuent à porter cette aide là et
puis l'assurance on a besoin de pouvoir
assurer des produits innovants plus vite
qu'on le fait aujourd'hui
on a besoin de pouvoir
assurer ceux qui émettent une garantie
de performance au bénéfice des maîtres
d'ouvrage voilà à grand trait ce que
j'évoque moi je crois à la possibilité
de seau industriel j'espère que votre
commission le suggéra mais ça supposera
alors un pilotage politique
unique une incarnation du sujet
et non pas une dispersion de la maîtrise
du sujet voilà l'alternative qui s'offre
à nous
merci merci madame la Présidente merci
pour vos
exposés et la vision assez large du coup
vous avez pu vous avez pu développer
peut-être une petite remarque c'est vrai
que sur le les zones d'ombre et de
lumière
je partage moins la
lumière on va dire sur le fait que enfin
je suis d'accord avec vous sur le fait
qu'on peut pas dire qu'il y a rien n'a
été fait il y a des orientations qui
sont très fortes et des objectifs qui
ont été mis il y a des moyens aussi
enfin on voit bien qu'il y a on peut pas
dire que c'est
politique publique qui soit mise en
place mais c'est vrai qu'on peut se dire
aussi que le résultat il est loin et
très loin de ce qu'on pourrait attendre
et en tout cas on est très loin des
objectifs qui sont atteints la raison
justement de se pencher sur la question
et de se dire pourquoi pourquoi
justement on n'arrive pas à atteindre
ces objectifs et en tout cas que si on
suit cette trajectoire ça risque d'être
très long et trop long quoi
non peut-être par rapport à ce que vous
avez dit peut-être plutôt sur à la fois
sur la fin moi il y avait quelque chose
qui m'intéressait peut-être que vous
pouvez peut-être plus développer c'est
comment vous voyez la place justement
des collectivités territoriales parce
que je pense enfin moi ça me paraît
aussi fondamental de de d'agir en
proximité et que en plus on n'agit pas
de la même manière suivant le type de
territoire et donc la place justement
des collectivités territoriales à
travers des plateformes de rénovation
dont on a déjà vu enfin voilà tout
l'intérêt et de voir comment du coup on
pouvait s'appuyer justement sur ces sur
ces collectivités
deux questions plus techniques mais je
sais que vous avez un petit peu
travaillé sur la question à la fois sur
le les DPE et l'évolution du DPE tel
qu'il est puisqu'on sait que c'est un
outil indispensable puisque ça c'est un
peu sur cet outil là dont on va se baser
pour toutes les politiques publiques qui
seront mises en place donc peut-être
votre regard sur l'évolution du DPE et
en tout cas tel qu'il est actuellement
et puis également sur label RGE sur les
entreprises et puis ça me permettra de
terminer sur ce que vous avez dit sur la
politique industrielle mais sur pareil
sur le RGE c'est vrai qu'il y a un choix
qui a été qui a été fait en France de
plutôt partir sur une labellisation et
de d'entreprises dont on s'aperçoit
qu'il y a quand même des limites puisque
on voit que c'est pas du non plus la
belle très très complexe à obtenir
mais d'un autre côté on s'aperçoit aussi
qu'il y a plein d'entreprises qui donc
qui ne sont pas forcément labellisés qui
cherchent même pas forcément à l'être
alors que pourrait aller sur ces marchés
là et voilà et donc peut-être une
réflexion sur le fait de est-ce qu'on
n'apparaît pas plutôt intérêt à
travailler sur le l'obligation résultat
quoi et donc du coup d'avoir plutôt un
contrôle en fin de chantier qui permet
de réellement s'assurer que les travaux
sont correctement réalisés alors que là
actuellement on fait l'inverse qu'on dit
labellise une entreprise en disant que
parce qu'elle est labellisée les travaux
seront réellement fait correctement et
puis sur ce que vous disiez sur la
politique industrielle moi je partage
assez enfin l'idée en tout cas de dire
que si on veut arriver à
aux enjeux qui sont qui sont face à nous
et si on veut le faire de à grande
échelle et assez rapidement ça veut dire
que derrière on a toute une filière à
mettre en place
et que même si on met de l'argent comme
ça on sait bien que il va falloir à la
fois les entreprises à la fois la
formation à la fois les matériaux et se
pose aussi la question justement des
filières
global qu'on peut mettre en place mais
peut-être plus spécifiquement sur la
question des matériaux
parce que là c'est pareil je pense que
localement on peut à la fois sur la
question des matériaux biosourcés sur
comment on peut mieux
produire des matériaux localement je
pense que ça c'est un vrai enjeu parce
que derrière il y a tout un
développement aussi économique à la fois
des emplois et puis peut-être sur la
question des matériaux biosourcés aussi
et la question du carbone
puisque c'est vrai qu'actuellement je
crois que les 90% des matériaux qui sont
utilisés sont des matériaux
issus de l'industrie pétrochimique et à
l'inverse on sait que si on travaille
sur la paille le champ enfin peu importe
sur l'ensemble des matériaux sourcils ou
le bois en même temps c'est un manière
de capter du carbone et donc du coup qui
pourrait aussi être rémunéré et qui
pourrait permettre aussi d'alimenter
cette filière voilà si vous le permettez
je laisse le soin à Marie Gracia
de de répondre à ces questions et
j'apporterai peut-être un contrepoint
mais elle elle les maîtrise bien
[Musique]
sur le service public de la rénovation
énergétique
il est essentiel dans le rôle de tiers
de confiance qui peut apporter au ménage
et on sait bien que d'autant plus
aujourd'hui où on se retrouve dans une
situation où on a des écoles délinquants
qui sont certes une minorité mais qui
font énormément de tort à la filière de
rénovation énergétique on a besoin
d'avoir ce tiers de confiance qui puisse
accompagner le ménage le rassurer tout
au long de sa prise de décision mais
aussi aller plus loin accompagner les
travaux et ça fait partie de ce qui peut
en assurer la performance et la qualité
à terme sur le service public
il se déploie il va plus loin qu'il n'a
pu être au fur et à mesure et Philippe
évoquait le nombre d'espaces conseils
aujourd'hui sur le territoire il reste
quand même des questions sur son
financement à la fin de l'année le
financement actuel à travers le
programme
c2ofinancé par les collectivités
territoriales s'arrêtent ça veut dire
que dans neuf mois on ne sait pas
comment sera financer ce service public
alors même que les collectivités
attendent d'avoir des orientations de
l'État pour pouvoir enclencher en
fonction les cofinancement adéquat ou
pas et savoir quels sont les
orientations qui seront données donc on
a là un outil qu'on a construit au fur
et à mesure des années qui a fait ses
preuves et qui nécessiteraient d'être en
tout cas stabilisé dans le temps sans
avoir l'inquiétude de savoir si dans 9
mois on doit renvoyer les conseillers
qui sont sur les territoires aujourd'hui
sur ça me permet de d'aussi compléter
avec le volet accompagnement que je vais
relier à la question que vous posiez sur
finalement les résultats en termes de
travaux et la performance attente quand
on a des projets de rénovation qui sont
accompagnés aujourd'hui notamment par
les dispositifs publics et du service
public existant on a la preuve qu'à la
fin les la performance est au
rendez-vous parce que les choix de
travaux auront été les bons ils seront
faits avec les bons niveaux d'ambition
avec une rénovation globale et
performante qui sera projetée dans le
temps les financements auront pu être
trouvés et compléter et surtout
l'accompagnement va au-delà du choix des
travaux mais bien pendant les travaux
jusqu'à la réception et c'est là une
preuve de sa nécessité là aussi un
certain nombre de questions sur le
financement notamment de mon
accompagnateur rénov et son déploiement
pleinement opérationnel qui doit arriver
prochainement
deuxième point que vous évoquiez c'est
sur le DPE
le DPE est un outil formidable et qui
est peut-être celui qui a le mieux
fonctionné puisque aujourd'hui c'est le
seul qui est connu par l'ensemble des
Français sur le sujet de la performance
énergétique peut-être pas connu pour les
bonnes raisons si on se fait les
épisodes de ces derniers mois pour
autant dans son rôle initial pour lequel
il a été inventé c'est-à-dire un outil
de sensibilisation à la performance
énergétique de son logement il
fonctionne il a été fiabilisé il y a eu
une réforme nécessaire pour pouvoir
appliquer la même méthode à l'ensemble
des bâtiments quel que soit leur année
de construction mais en tout cas dans ce
rôle là il joue aujourd'hui pleinement
son rôle et sensibilise il permet de
situer la performance de son logement de
prendre conscience par contre on lui a
donné un rôle aujourd'hui qui dépasse
largement le cadre initial de la
sensibilisation des ménages on lui a
donné un rôle dans l'ensemble de la
politique publique de rénovation
énergétique qui est peut-être trop lourd
à faire porter sur ce seul outil en
toute état de cause c'est pas un outil
qui a été conçu pour concevoir des
projets de travaux et c'est là une
question autour de l'audit énergétique
réglementaire et des audits incitatifs
qui utilisent la même méthode mais qui
ne permettent pas forcément d'aller sur
les bons chemins
donc voilà c'est dans son état initial
je pense qu'il remplit son rôle mais
attention à vouloir adosser toute la
politique publique notamment quand on
connaît encore aujourd'hui les problèmes
dans sa réalisation et la fiabilité qui
peut avoir sur le terrain et les
problèmes qui sont assez largement
remontés
et enfin peut-être pour revenir sur
sur les derniers sujets sur RGE et la
question de la qualité de l'offre c'est
certain que nous ne sommes pas au niveau
c'est RGE a permis d'enclencher une
dynamique qui était celle d'avoir une
formation d'un nombre important
d'artisans et professionnels mais
aujourd'hui c'est pas suffisant et il y
a certainement une réflexion à mener
pour d'une part arrêter la baisse au fur
et à mesure des années du nombre de
professionnels qui sont qualifiés RGE et
puis ensuite se concentrer au bon
endroit je regardais avant avant cette
audition le nombre de professionnels RGE
qualifiés rénovation globale il y en a
moins de 300 sur l'ensemble du
territoire je vois pas comment sur ce
constat on peut aller au niveau et
surtout
alors je concerne les personnes qui font
les travaux qui sont essentiels mais
faut pas oublier tout ce qui va être du
rôle de l'accompagnement de l'assistance
à maîtrise d'ouvrage de la maîtrise
d'oeuvre ou là aussi on a un sujet
d'une offre suffisante sur l'ensemble du
territoire aujourd'hui des particuliers
qui veulent se lancer sur des travaux
ont du mal à trouver un bureau d'études
qui va leur faire le bon audit et les
amener sur le chemin d'une rénovation
énergétique performante c'est déjà une
réalité si demain on met réellement les
moyens qu'il faut pour atteindre nos
objectifs c'est à dire une rénovation
globale et performante c'est d'aller
vers le niveau BBC on voit bien qu'on
manque de professionnelle qualifiés pour
faire ses études et faire la bonne
planification des travaux et je ne pense
pas que le fait d'avoir de permettre aux
diagnostiqueur immobilier de réaliser
l'audit énergétique réglementaire
réponse à cette question aujourd'hui
donc hier on est fort là-dessus à faire
et dernier point que vous aviez opté les
matériaux bio sourcés la question de
l'empreinte carbone
c'est effectivement un sujet qui reste à
déployer je pense qu'aujourd'hui
beaucoup de collectivités notamment déjà
soutiennent le développement des
filières locales de matériaux biosour
cgossés et ça identité
en tout cas à leur mise en oeuvre j'ai
l'exemple de la région Normandie par
exemple qui a qui a mis en bonus sur
l'utilisation de matériaux biosourcés
sur la rénovation énergétique où on voit
bien que
dans les résultats qui peut y avoir ce
bonus il est ce qu'il est pour autant il
incite sur des rénovations aller
chercher ces matériaux donc c'est un
sujet de développement qui va falloir
accompagner dans sa montée en puissance
avec la montée en puissance du nombre de
rénovations pour pouvoir être
rendez-vous et répondre mais je me
permets juste un petit complément sur ça
on élargissant un tout petit peu la
question du carbone en rénovation
on a aujourd'hui dans le discours en
tout cas
de l'État une volonté de très forte
d'aller sur la décarbonation rénovation
et à juste titre on a un besoin et des
objectifs en matière de neutralité
carbone à l'horizon 2050 et c'est
essentiel que la filière du bâtiment y
répondent pour autant il faut pas que le
sujet de la décarbonation oublie celui
de l'efficacité énergétique en matière
de rénovation il est essentiel que les
deux fonctionnent ensemble quand on a
retravaillé sur le label BBC on y a
introduit des mesures qui nous
permettent de parler de basse
consommation et bas carbone les deux
doivent aller ensemble et la rénovation
énergétique peut pas se résumer à
décarboner les énergies de cheveux
utilisés dans le chauffage ce qui est
aujourd'hui un petit peu trop le cas
et si je peux ajouter un mot à ce propos
je
pense que nous allons évoluer assez vite
dans
l'acception
que nous donnerons aux mots rénovation
vous auriez créé cette commission il y a
cinq ans vous auriez parlé probablement
de rénovation thermique vous parlez
aujourd'hui de rénovation énergétique en
élargissant la maille à la fourniture
d'énergie et ça et sa maîtrise stop je
pense que très vite dans trois ans
quatre ans cinq ans votre prochaine
commission sur le sujet parlera de
rénovation environnementale parce que
comme le dit Marie la question du
carbone
vacheminer peut-être plus vite que les
puisque des politiques publiques et moi
je crois que le sujet en réalité est
encore plus ample et que
le couple construction rénovation qu'on
a cherché à séparer
scindé etc est un couple en réalité
assez proche et si on veut mener une
politique industrielle c'est sur
l'ensemble qu'il faut jouer et de même
quand on se préoccupe des personnes
qu'on loge ou qui viennent travailler
dans ces locaux la question de
la qualité énergétique la question de la
sobriété environnementale du bâti elle
doit être mariée avec la question de la
santé des occupants et la question de
l'adaptation du logement au
vieillissement des habitants en somme je
crois que le champ de vision doit être
élargi la Rénovation Énergétique est une
partie du sujet mais par exemple
euh je j'ai l'intuition que si comme
prévu l'année prochaine m'a pris
m'adapte et distribuée et qu'on a de
manière intelligente
articulée m'adapte avec ma prime rénove
c'est par l'adaptation que des personnes
âgées qui n'ont pas le courage de se
lancer dans une action énergétique
pourront très trop l'adaptation parce
qu'elle met en cause leur maintien dans
les lieux pour leur vieillesse et ce
point-là est considérable pour elle et
c'est probablement à nous de faire en
sorte d'embarquer la performance
énergétique à l'occasion de l'adaptation
du logement qui aura là une entrée dans
le sujet qui sera probablement plus
vigoureuse que la simple entrée
énergétique
un ministre que vous avez interrogé
Emmanuel vargon disait que on se
réveille pas le matin en disant qu'on va
faire une rénovation énergétique
probablement qu'elle avait raison et
plus on est âgé plus la complexité la
complexité de la rénovation d'un bien en
site occupé est une question majeure
François non
je voulais vous demander sur vous avez
parlé de l'instabilité excessive du
statut de la copropriété qui est un des
problèmes importants parce que pour
faire une rénovation que soit les
copropriétés dégradées au début ou
toutes les copropriété c'est très
compliqué
quels sont les solutions que vous
verriez pour qu'on sorte ce problème
parce que là on avancerait quand même il
y a pas mal de copropriétés et la
deuxième question je trouve que l'idée
de la filière industrielle de la
construction est une excellente idée et
ça serait très intéressant parce que
c'est très très intéressant pour notre
industrie parce qu'on aura un modèle
industriel avec de la production
industrielle etc bon et on aurait aussi
sa stimulerait aussi la recherche sur
les matériaux et procédés
et je pense que ça c'est quelque chose
qui m'a intéressé voilà
je commence par répondre à la dernière
question avant de revenir à à la
première sur la dernière question j'ai
mentionné à la fois comme une faiblesse
et comme un espoir la recherche est
développement dans ce secteur qui est
d'une pauvreté ainsi
des industriels des grands industriels
ont un pôle R&D mais l'ensemble de la
filière ne réfléchit pas et on est dans
une logique de récurrence on fait comme
faisait les anciens et on y trouve
d'ailleurs une qualité à l'égard de ses
clients je pense qu'on doit pouvoir
ménager l'expérience des anciens mais
aussi entrer dans un monde plus innovant
qui les compliquée dans d'envahir parce
que l'innovation est je l'ai évoqué d'un
mot difficile à assurer
assurer
en France l'innovation
éprouvée dans un pays étranger de notre
Europe est reçu en France avec beaucoup
de prudence et et de besoin d'avis
techniques supplémentaire donc on a là
on a là une toute un travail
d'un regard plus plus accueillant à
l'égard de l'innovation pour conduire
ces développements la première
observation que vous m'avez voilà sur la
copropriété
alors d'abord j'ai une attitude du
juriste que je suis c'est de ne toucher
que d'une main tremblante aux lois en
vigueur ensuite ensuite je veux vous
faire état de deux expériences la
lumière un nombre excessif de syndic de
copropriété qui m'ont dit le jour où tu
arrêteras de changer la loi ce jour-là
on s'y mettra alors c'est un artifice
pour montrer le peu d'envie de se saisir
du sujet et estimé trop complexe mais
c'est un artifice qui ne faut pas
favoriser nous avons beaucoup changé
cette règle et la deuxième expérience
c'est celle des jurys que je préside
régulièrement et dont un qui concerne
l'espace métropolitain francilien
mené par l'agence parisienne du climat
qui récompense des copropriétés qui ont
réussi à progresser et bien on voit
de très grosses copropriété des
copropriétés plus petites
occupées par des gens dont la qualité
principale n'est pas d'être riche
et et on voit des gains de 50 à 60%
d'économie d'énergie réalisée par les
travaux qu'ils arrivent à financer donc
oui ça fonctionne alors quelle est la
quelle est la clé c'est un syndic qui a
compris que ce n'est pas seul qu'il
pourrait mener la barque et il constitue
une équipe une équipe projet dans lequel
il y a le bureau d'études l'architecte
celui qui sait parler aux
copropriétaires et leur expliquer en 3D
ce que sera l'immeuble de demain
l'économiste qui fait l'économise de la
construction qui fait une sorte de
projection de ce que sera l'économie
d'énergie qui permettra en partie de
financer
c'est un travail lourd mais quand on
quand on remet un prix monte sur la
tribune ça se passe à l'hôtel de ville
de Paris monte à la 3 4 fois que je
préside ce jury monte à la tribune 15
personnes
15 personnes il y a le président du
conseil syndical bien entendu le syndic
mais des quantités de gens qui ont été
partis prenantes de cette œuvre
collective donc oui ça ça fonctionne et
donc ma recommandation aujourd'hui c'est
de dire que la loi 2010 et les
aménagements faits dans allure et dans
élan suffisent à donner un arsenal
juridique qui permet de faire
fonctionner la rénovation d'une
copropriété voilà je je
peux toujours rester dans ce rêve de la
France qui est celui de l'excellence de
la loi qui favorise tout tellement elle
est bonne je pense que la vraie vie
montre qu'on peut s'accommoder de loi
qui sort de bonne facture même s'il y a
encore quelques aspérités
écoutez merci beaucoup
Madame la Directrice nous en fait
partager non seulement voilà l'état
actuel mais aussi de nous avoir donné
des des préconisations sur l'état
projeté est un futur en tout cas on
utilisera avec bon escient dans le cadre
de nos travaux merci et on vous souhaite
une bonne soirée merci beaucoup